there's his numbers in 10 starts this
season 56 innings a great 2.89 era
ground ball percentage very good looking
to build off that
this will be a second start after coming
off the injured list
the wind and the delivery in a swing and
a miss and got him
on the breaking ball the slider just off
the outside corner
and tim anderson goes down on strikes
and the pitch and this one
reached out hidden right field it'll be
easy for mccormick
yo glove it and the astros retire the
side white sox go down one two
three in the first the astros coming to
bat the scoreless game
dallas kykel in that chicago white sox
uniform making his first start
in this ballpark as a visitor spent
seven years in that astros uniform 2015
cy young award winner this season in 14
starts he is six and one with a three
seven eight
and altuve drills one down the left
field line that'll be a fair ball
and jose altuve who dallas has seen
with a lot of extra bass hits and hits
in general in his career
gets one off dallas to start this game
first and third nobody out and that'll
bring up michael brantley
1-2 he struck him out that is a nasty
change up and now one away
bases will be loaded for the big man
jordan alvarez having a good series he
has a five-game hitting streak going
called strike three oh my goodness
gracious
alvarez thought he had taken ball four
in a one-nothing lead instead
it was the change-up now abraham toro
with the bases loaded in two outs
ground ball towards the hole stopped by
anderson and
safe at first base toro one-nothing
astro
altuve scores and the astros take a
one-nothing lead
hits one on a hop to the second baseman
mendick and he'll step on the bag there
to force toro
and that will end the first inning it
was eventful
and he drills one into right for a base
hit
over to cut it off is mccormick and
he'll keep
grand all to a very loud single
that'll bring up jake lamb with two outs
227 average
four home runs he's knocked in eight
here comes
drive to right that baby will
go a two run homer jake lamb
and the white sox have the lead that was
an
absolute rocket about two rows deep
close to the right field corner jake
lamb sitting on something in
he did indeed get that barrel to it with
no problem or hesitation junior on the
mound
a ball in two strikes hand over the head
in the wind up here's the pitch and it's
a swing and a miss
high fastball mendix swings right
through it that's the third strikeout
for lance and there's one away oh two
swinging a miss
strike three on the high fastball again
and that's four strikeouts
here's the 2-2 breaker ball it's
grounded up the middle backhanded out
two bay
uh bounce though to first in time gets
abreu
on a fancy play up the middle by the
astros gold glove second baseman we'll
go to the bottom of the third
chaz with an infield hit his first time
up on a wide throw by montana that was
ruled a hit
swinging a miss strike three on a cutter
nice job by he
and brondahl as carlos breaks his bat
sends it into center field goodwin
coming on he won't get there what a read
by michael brantley trying to go first
to third he will
correa caught between first and second
and carlos trying to stay in the run
down the ball
bobbered and everybody's going to be
safe correa kept staying in the rundown
long enough to cause an extra throw but
anderson bobbled
and he ends up keeping himself and the
rally alive
gordon who came up in a big spot last
time bats here with second and third and
one out
the pitch a liner to left center field
that could get down
and it does bradley will score correa on
his heels
it's three to two a two run single by
jordan
got a pitch on the outer third and just
went with it
jones drives one to left field that's
well struck and that'll be
off the top of the wall jordan alvarez
will score
to third goes toro rbi double for taylor
jones astros lead four to two
now altuve faces tycho here with the
bases loaded in two outs
outside ball four bases loaded walk
astros at a run it's now
five to two alice will watch the manager
with the slow walk out to the mound
shortest outing of the season for dallas
kykel he faces his whole team for the
very first time
so 74 pitches for kykel
and it's a standing ovation from the
astros fans this is fantastic you're
talking about class
these astros fans showing dallas cockle
the utmost respect right now
he's chas mccormick here bases loaded
two outs in a 5-2 game
let kick here it is and it's inside ball
four another walk
and that'll be another run for the
astros it's 6-2
the 0-2 swinging a bouncer towards
second base
anderson will step on the bag just in
time to get mccormick
and the inning finally over astros leads
6-2 bottom of the fourth want to keep
that foot on the pedal right now carlos
correa will try
and that one's ripped big time to left
field here we go
14th home run of the season for correa
and it's 7-2
that was gone off the barrel three two
pitch how about this
abraham toro toro toro he has three for
three
swinging a miss strike three and that's
it for the astros in the fourth correa
led off with a homer
30 throws hard hasn't appeared in too
many games only three this season
strike three called straw
is out one down maldonado at first base
there's two outs we're in the fifth
seven two astros on top to swing and
this would
hit a mile in the air to shallow center
field
second baseman out center fielder and
that will drop it dropped right by
between the base runners maldonado goes
to third base
first and third with two outs castro's
trying to take advantage of this
situation here
here's the pitch and that one right back
up the middle to be an rbi single into
center field
mccormick will go to third base
maldonado scores
and the astros lead it eight to two
here's the pitch
ground ball up the middle off the leg of
birdie and it kicks right to mendic
and shadow right now throw him out the
white sox finally got a break
bertie fortunately is all right that'll
go one to four to three
new pitcher on the mound it is aaron
bummer 28 appearances this season
0-4 with a 3-8-6 he's batting from the
right side here to lead off and that one
is grounded and it's up the middle for a
base hit
toro toro toro toro has done it again
with a four hit game wow
astros leading 8-2 here he had the pitch
swing and a miss and he struck him
out so altuve goes down to a knee with
the swing and the miss
3-2 pitch is hit to deep left center
field
goodwin a long run near the wall leaps
up and it's off the wall brantley has
two
he will now head to third he was
debating
and a head first line for us to mike for
a triple
two and two from hoyer slider in
and a great play by abreu and the astros
do not score in the seventh they strand
brantley at
third ralph garza jr takes over here in
the night
oh two and this is a pitch and did he
hold up he
did not and that is a strikeout ralph
garza jr comes in and carves up tim
anderson on three pitches
and another good change up boncata goes
down
on strikes back-to-back strikeouts for
garza jr coming out of the bullpen
with two outs a walk a double in another
walk and the bases are loaded
pop-up playable the blue hair of martine
maldonado camps underneath it and puts
it away for the final out
the astros sweep the white sox
they move into first place in the al
west by percentage points